imposante et fragile de la trace vous ne
pouvez l'ignorer
ir entièrement enfoui sous la végétation
la vieille bâtisse aurait pu s'écrouler
un immeuble neuf aurait alors pris sa
place comme c'est si souvent le cas mais
la détermination d'une famille en a
décidé autrement
muriel et olivier ont acquis la maison
pour la sauver et leurs dossiers pour le
loto du patrimoine a totalement séduit
olivier ihl état ville avait plus de doc
mais moi j'étais convaincu que en
alliage et quand on croit à quelque
chose c'est sûr que l'on met en place
toutes les ondes positives pour que le
projet se réalise il faut croire en ce
qu'on fait c'est ça qui fait la réussite
d'abord on a été touchés quand on a su
qu'on avait été retenu
ça ça a été quelque chose d'exceptionnel
ensuite on a été touché par le fait
qu'on nous allons nous a accordé
l'intégralité des sommes qu'on avait
demandé et ça c'était pas gagné non plus
le résultat de l'opération mis en place
avec la française des jeux a eu un
impact considérable
désormais il y à du travail
des murs au plafond de l'installation
électrique à la toiture
car si la famille campe ici à la merci
de la pluie
c'est vraiment paramo les 150000 euros
de la mission berne ne sont là pour
sécuriser un bâtiment en péril le reste
des travaux assurera les finitions et le
confort des occupants
nous voulons en faire un lieu de
d'événements pour la martinique
les martiniquais qui veulent faire un
événement un mariage mais aussi l'ouvrir
au tourisme bien sûr puisque le tourisme
vert c'est un apport essentiel je pense
je pense est complémentaire au tourisme
bleus ici
[Musique]
la préservation de cet endroit je sais
que c'est aussi pour nous donc je trouve
que c'est un très beau geste
un beau geste d'amour et puis de
dévotion parce qu'elle s'investit aussi
pour lille pour que les gens puissent
profiter en fait de cet héritage qui
leur a été lesté et qui était laissé à
l'abandon
donc je trouve ça super en matière de
restauration tout est possible avec les
financements plus que jamais la mission
berne incite les propriétaires à voir la
valeur patrimoniale de leur ville
demeure usine leurs vieux moulin ou
ateliers les dossiers pour 2020 sont à
remplir en ligne jusqu'au 31 décembre